bienvenue à tous Paris
Saclay TV mais le principe reste le même
vous tenir informé de toute l'actualité
de votre territoire au programme de
cette émission gros plan sur le cluster
santé c'est l'un des cinq domaines
stratégiques du plateau de Saclay vous
en saurez plus dans un instant qui dit
cluster dit innovation ouverte et donc
FabLab mais qu'est-ce que c'est élément
de réponse avec Romain divozzo
responsable du FabLab digiscope qui se
trouve juste derrière moi et pour
attirer plus d'entreprises sur votre
territoire il faut savoir répondre à
leurs attentes c'est le credo de
l'association Paul VI nous les avons
rencontrés enfin nous on viendrons sur
cette journée découverte en réalité par
l'IRT système X l'Institut nous a
proposé un parcours pour mieux
comprendre l'ingénierie numérique des
systèmes vous saurez tout enfin un autre
agenda avec les temps forts tous les
événements à ne pas rater en ce mois de
mars ce sera à la fin de cette émission
pareil Saclay c'est déjà un cluster à
lui tout seul votre territoire a fait le
pari de l'innovation ouverte les plus
grandes entreprises collaborent avec les
laboratoires publics les grandes écoles
les startups un cluster qui compte 5
grands domaines 5 secteurs stratégiques
nous allons vous les présenter tout au
long de ces émissions on commence avec
celui de la santé 130 entreprises 14000
salariés et de nombreux défis à relever
voyez ce reportage
en matière de médecine personnalisée il
y a un domaine d'activité qui est très
intéressant et très important c'est
l'activité ticket santé donc les
technologies de la formation et la
communication à santé qui vont permettre
de développer des produits des solutions
multi technologiques et des services qui
vont accompagner les traitements
dans la prise en charge du patient au
quotidien
les clusters de l'innovation en e-santé
ou ticket santé ont commencé aujourd'hui
à travailler de manière collaborative
très étroitement à la fois avec des
grands groupes industriels des PME
innovants des startups pour la partie
entreprise des académies et puis les
établissements de santé privés et public
puisque pour pouvoir développer des
solutions pertinentes auxquelles du
patient il faut bien sûr accéder aux
patients et donc on a décidé d'impliquer
l'Assistance Publique des Hôpitaux de
Paris et les hospital universitaires
pour développer ces solutions et santé
télémédecine TIC et Santé dans le
territoire Paris région
sauf développe des logiciels de
modélisation et de simulation du
médicament des essais cliniques il
s'agit de technologie qui permettent de
mettre en équation le comportement de
médicaments dans le corps humain les
effets sur la maladie le comportement de
la maladie et surtout ce qui est le plus
difficile de faire des estimations
statistiques des paramètres de ces
modèles et de comprendre comment les
choses vont varier donc dans le cadre
notamment de cette clinique d'un
individuel à l'autre donc on combine à
la fois le travail de modélisation avec
le travail d'estimation statistique pour
comprendre les variations entre les
différents patients
on maintient partenariat très étroit
avec une règle c'est à dire une
collaboration de recherche et on
travaille également avec des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques dans les
environs en particulier Sanofi par
exemple avec lesquels on connaît un
logiciel de simulation d'essai clinique
à ses pointures donc on travaille à la
fois avec des laboratoires de recherche
et des compagnies
c'est important de comprendre que pour
pouvoir mener des développements dans
ces domaines
stratégiques il faut agir de manière
innovation ouverte entre guillemets et
dans la mesure où ces technologies sont
maîtrisées par différents acteurs
industriels ou par différents acteurs
académiques ou universitaires et que
seul on peut pas développer des
solutions d'un bout à l'autre de la
chaîne de valeur dans ce domaine
d'activité
connaissez-vous les fablabs il s'agit
d'une sorte de laboratoire d'un atelier
partagé orienté vers la fabrication
numérique il participe de fait à
l'innovation ouverte ce concept assez
récent prend toute sa place apparaît sa
clé nous sommes à Digiteo qui accueille
un grand nombre de fablabs maintenant il
faut les organiser les mettre en réseau
les ouvrir au plus grand nombre
rencontre avec le fablabber Romain Dijon
un FabLab c'est un laboratoire de
fabrication numérique c'est le type de
projet qui a démarré il y a une dizaine
d'années au MIT
l'idée c'est de déposer les outils de
fabrication numérique entre les mains
des utilisateurs et donc de les mettre
dans la situation où ils peuvent
effectivement fabriquer leurs objets
eux-mêmes dans un FabLab
en principe notre FabLab et dédié à la
production d'objets pour l'interaction
machine et pour la visualisation de
données donc on est plutôt dans le champ
des computing science
le réseau des fablabs qui se constitue
sur le plateau de sa clé il est encore
assez informel mais on sait qu'il y a un
certain nombre d'initiatives qui sont en
cours parce que je participe à un groupe
de travail porté par la FCS donc la
fondation du Campus Paris Saclay donc il
y a un certain nombre d'initiatives qui
sont à la fois au niveau de l'Université
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines une école
qui s'appelle l'ESTACA ensuite
évidemment pour les ce qui existe déjà
il y a le 503 qui fait partie de
l'Institut d'Optique on a ensuite le ns
cachant l'IUT ens de Cachan qui
effectivement a déjà des pratiques de ce
type là aussi on a aux Ulis aussi un
FabLab mobile qui a été mis en place il
y a d'autres initiatives d'ailleurs un
tas de collaboration qui sont en train
de se faire cependant tous les fablabs
en question pour l'instant ne sont pas
ouverts à tous les publics donc il ne
remplissent pas complètement leur
T-shirt de FabLab
les forces de ce réseau de FabLab ou
d'innovelables si on peut utiliser un
autre terme pour décrire des fablabs qui
sont pas encore tout à fait des fables
c'est c'est cette dimension territoriale
et programmatique c'est à dire qu'il y a
un certain nombre d'installations qui
sont en train d'être construites il y a
un maillage il y a il y a un réseau qui
va permettre à des gens notamment moi et
d'autres fablabs de partager des publics
ça ça va être vraiment très très
intéressant et en termes d'innovation à
la fois technologique et sociétale ce
sera une belle expérience à suivre
pour inciter les entreprises à
s'installer sur le plateau de Paris
Saclay il faut savoir répondre à leurs
attentes c'est le credo de Paul vie une
association d'entreprise écouter les
précisions d'Hervé Plessis directeur du
Centre Daniel Carrasso de Danone
Research groupe membres de Paul vie
ça veut dire pôle de vie voilà
c'est-à-dire qu'on ait une association
qui travaillons pour développer un pôle
de vie pour toutes les personnes qui
travaillent sur le plateau de Saclay
les fondateurs de Paul vie sont au
nombre de 7 donc il y a Thalès oriba le
C2N le CEA la fille qui est une
association de formation d'apprentis
soleil et puis Danone
depuis sa fondation Paul vise c'est
beaucoup agrandi avec l'adhésion de
nouveaux employeurs ou de nouvelles
entreprises et aujourd'hui on a une
trentaine de membres qui sont à la fois
des grandes entreprises des startups et
aussi un certain nombre de centres de
recherche liés à des écoles ou à
l'université car ils sont tous
employeurs de personnes voilà qui
travaillent sur le plateau de Saclay
voilà l'association continue de grandir
et donc nous avons chaque jour de
nouveaux membres qui vont se joindre à
nous
les membres de l'association Paul vie
c'est un regroupe à peu près 30 000
postes de travail on a je vous l'ai dit
beaucoup de gens qui travaillent dans
nos entreprises ces personnes elles
doivent se déplacer elles doivent vivre
sur le plateau elles doivent se loger
nos grands projets nos grands axes de
travail aujourd'hui c'est les transports
en commun donc l'arrivée futur de la
ligne 18 où sera-t-elle comment
va-t-elle desservir notre plateau mais
aussi comment va-t-on vivre et se
déplacer en attendant l'arrivée de la
ligne 18 la deuxième grand sujet c'est
les services créer sur le plateau des
espaces de restauration et de détente
pour nos salariés et enfin nous
travaillons aussi sur les questions de
logement pour que voilà les gens qui
travaillent dans nos entreprises
puissent habiter à proximité
en agissant ensemble évidemment on est
plus fort et plus efficace que si
chacune de ces entreprises essaye d'agir
par ses propres moyens
on veut favoriser les conditions de vie
sur le plateau et ça évidemment ça va
attirer des nouvelles entreprises donc
on peut dire indirectement voilà qu'on
est là aussi pour créer tout un
écosystème favorable à l'emploi
rien ne vaut une bonne expérience une
bonne démonstration l'IRT système X a
décidé de nous faire mieux comprendre
l'ingénierie numérique des systèmes avec
une journée spéciale une journée pour
s'installer à bord d'un simulateur de
conduite de venir expert en optimisation
encore manipuler les données des réseaux
sociaux notre équipe était sur place
nous sommes ici pour notre événement
futuriste le troisième que l'on organise
et qui présente des activités de l'IRT
systémix et puis exactement qu'est-ce
que l'ingénierie numérique des systèmes
dans ce cadre-là il s'agit de comprendre
le travail que fait un ingénieur dans ce
domaine du numérique pour concevoir
développer valider et tester l'ensemble
de ces nouveaux produits qui incluent de
plus en plus de numérique
il y a une idée simple un produit est
compétitif soit parce qu'il est moins
cher soit parce qu'il est meilleur et il
est meilleur parce qu'il apporte quelque
chose de nouveau aux clients et cette
innovation elle résulte une invention
mais elle résulte aussi d'un progrès
technique et se progrès technique il se
construit par une collaboration
recherche industrie et donc l'innovation
c'est les gens qui travaillent ensemble
pour un plus qui a porté au client
le défi de liberté systémique et de
s'insérer au sein du plateau de Saclay
sur ces dimensions ingénieurs et système
en s'appuyant à la fois du côté
académique sur la nouvelle université
Paris-Saclay et du côté industriel sur
l'ensemble de l'écosystème qui a
constitué le pôle de compétitivité
systématique on arrive ainsi avec ces
deux piliers à les faire travailler
ensemble et aborder des problématiques
qui sont tirées par le marché sur des
cas d'usage et qui sont souvent
transversales par rapport à différents
marchés que sont le monde du transport
le monde de la sécurité le monde des
télécoms ou le monde de la cybersécurité
par exemple
Paris Saclay à vocation à devenir le
centre français et même le Centre
européen de rencontre entre les
entreprises l'industrie la recherche
fondamentale la recherche appliquée dans
un seul lieu dans un périmètre de 10 ou
15 km on retrouve des grands centres de
recherche industriels les meilleures
écoles et universités françaises et des
centres de recherche appliqués à la
pointe du progrès et donc ce dialogue
cette proximité géographique ce fait que
ces gens qui travaillent sur les sujets
voisins peuvent se rencontrer fait qu'on
y fera plus d'invention plus
d'innovation et donc pour construire à
l'avenir économique du pays
et maintenant comme promis notre agenda
vous aviez jusqu'au 15 mars pour vous
inscrire à la deuxième édition du
Challenge étudiant pour proposer vos
projets pour améliorer la qualité de vie
sur le campus Paris Saclay des services
innovants pour vous et tous ceux qui
sont sur le campus plus d'informations
sur notre site enfin des nouvelles du
chantier de l'ismo l'Institut des
Sciences moléculaires d'Orsay il avance
le gros œuvre du niveau R2 qui
comportera des machineries nécessaires à
la gestion du bâtiment est achevé le
gros œuvre du niveau R1 destiné aux
salles d'expérience les plus sensibles
aux vibrations est en bonne voie il sera
terminé en mars 2015 voilà c'est la fin
de ce numéro merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi on se retrouve très vite pour un
nouveau Paris-Saclay TV